this is the ROE River and if you believe
the hype it is the shortest river in the
world and through the miracle of modern
technology the waterproof camera on this
stick I can show you the full length of
it all the way from the source a
crystal-clear spring in giant Springs
State Park Montana flowing down 61
meters until it joins the much much much
larger Missouri River flowing to the
ocean
yeah the rivers just there and it really
is crystal clear while I was setting up
someone came along with some bottles and
filled him up for drinking water I was
off in VidCon in Los Angeles last week
as I record this now he's having dinner
with a few folks who make educational
videos when I mentioned that I was
coming here to talk about the shortest
river and if modest the conversation
didn't go well they kept raising
different objections seemed to get angry
just at the concept so eventually I
looked up the dictionary definition of
river in the Oxford English Dictionary a
large natural stream of water flowing in
a channel to the sea a lake or another
usually larger stream of the same kind
first objection this is man-made true
the course of this was refined by people
but so is the Los Angeles River and
that's still a river despite a lot of
people thinking it's just an overgrown
storm drain although to be fair the
Rogue River here didn't even have a name
until the eighties when some students
surveyed it and campaigned for it to be
named the shortest river the Guinness
Book of Records did eventually agree at
least for a while okay so the folks I
was talking to you but how do you know
it's the shortest that is a fair point
there have been long documented
arguments about whether this river is
even the shortest in the United States
and there are international flames too
like this short channel between two
lakes near avascular in Finland and I
was really skeptical before I got here
but yeah now I'm standing by hit I
genuinely think this is the shortest
river in the world it is a large natural
channel flowing in one direction to a
lake Pritz all with dictionary
definitions unless you want to argue
that it's not large enough but frankly
if it's large enough to drowning I think
it should count
you could try having more specifics
forget arguing about whether this is
natural how about saying that a river
starts and a source flows somewhere in a
consistent direction and
at a much bigger bit of water that
seemed like a great definition to me
until someone pointed out that that
would include water slides every time we
tried to nail down a definition it
slipped away I'll be honest I'm not
really here to show you the world's
shortest river because I can't because
there will always be quibbles about
definitions all the categories that we
tried to put the natural world into to
fit everything into maps and databases
all those categories have to be fuzzy
map makers have known for years that as
with so many things in the real world
easy to a river is not always a question
that can be answered with a binary
yes-or-no there is almost always an
exception to the rule the river is
whatever humans agree it is the exact
definition probably differs between
languages and cultures anyway and in the
end the Guinness Book of Records decided
not to have a listing for short history